hey guys uh welcome to code tech
tutorials my name is matt i want to talk
a little bit about a
job opportunity i had a couple years ago
that i thought was pretty interesting so
i just
wanted to share the story get it out
there it's uh
yeah since it's been a couple years i
don't think it's super
critical for me to hide much of this
information anymore and it's sort of an
interesting story that
you can definitely learn from if you're
looking for a developer position
as well it kind of kind of comes in two
parts there's a there's like a good
thing about it you know and a bad thing
about it
so let's do it so when i graduated
college
and got my degree or a bachelor's degree
in computer science
naturally i wanted to work for some
company that i liked and a company that
i had
pretty much liked my entire life was
wizards of the coast magic the gathering
they make games like magic gathering and
dungeons and dragons and i was playing a
lot of dungeons and dragons so
i was kind of hoping to maybe get a
chance at
going over there as it's something i was
pretty passionate about and had been
doing for
well i guess most of my life at that
point i had also written a program
called
d empower which i'll link below if
you're curious
and it's basically a little bit of
software that helps you make characters
and helps a dm
run a dungeons and dragons game and it's
just something i worked on when i was a
new
c plus plus developer so based on that
and
uh yeah just just kind of
based on that and the experience i was i
was getting
and implementing parts of their game
into c plus plus already i thought hey
maybe this gives me a little bit of a
leg up
and i could have been right but
obviously i didn't get the job and i
wanted but i want to tell you the story
of how the interview went
and where i think it went awry
because i feel like for a while there i
had a pretty good shot and then at the
end i basically
i basically blew it and i kind of want
to get to that and
help you learn from my story because if
you have some job that you really want
um you the one of the main things you
want to do is you want to avoid
blowing it right all right so a couple
years ago
it's been more than a couple years i
applied to a position
at in renton west there uh washington
wren
washington which is pretty far from me
but i was open to
other places too or being fully remote
or or anything really i just kind of
wanted to
join the team if possible and get to get
to do some things over there
so full disclosure i had already
accepted another job at this point
because i applied and i didn't hear from
them for many months so i was also
looking for other stuff
and i did get another position at a
great place
as a c plus plus developer just helping
maintain a library it was like a math
library
i can't really say too much over about
the company because i
signed a lot of disclosure or whatever
it was called
a bunch of stuff dna
i think dna that's not the right word
you know what i'm talking about i'm
basically not a lot allowed to talk
about
the work i did there except in
generalities
so yeah i was basically just working
with a lot of
math and matrix math and library stuff
and
making code more efficient and stuff
like that and i really love the job i
really love my coworkers there so it was
great i wasn't exactly
looking to switch but hey if i could get
an opportunity at my dream place then i
guess i'm gonna go for it was kind of
where i was at
all right so what happened you're
probably wondering now
let's dig into it
so first of all
yeah i applied online i sent in a cover
letter i was
tried to be as open and honest about
things as i could and
you know i really didn't expect a
response
because they're just such a big company
and i was kind of a new developer fresh
out of school
not a ton of experience but i was pretty
passionate about it and i guess maybe
they saw that because i did
get a contact from someone there and
they wanted to set up an interview
so of course i accepted we set up a time
and we met for this interview over the
phone it was kind of the initial
interview
the initial interview was a bit hairy
because
well there were some issues with us
getting in contact for some reason
when they tried to call my phone didn't
ring i'm not entirely sure why
i was going through all the settings
trying to figure out why i felt like
maybe i had unknown numbers blocked but
i looked at that setting it did seem to
be set
so we had to reschedule a couple times
which was totally my fault and totally
due to the technology of my phone that
seemed to be out of my control so it was
a bit frustrating
i think it was just my phone service
provider at the time
so eventually i did end up switching to
a different provider
and this was one of the main reasons i
had to do that or i felt like i had to
do that because
if it was going to start costing me jobs
uh it's probably not
probably not the best phone service to
be paying for if it doesn't really work
too well
anyway we did eventually get it all set
up
and actually get in contact and
you know we just chatted for a while i
don't remember exactly how the
conversation
went but it seemed to go okay and
and we had we got a second interview
lined up and it was
with a more technical person now at this
stage i didn't exactly know
what position they were interviewing for
i didn't know for what game
they were i was potentially joining the
team of
as a software developer but on the
second interview
it was revealed that it was for magic
the gathering online mtgo
if you're not familiar with mgo it's
basically a little
card game well magic the gathering is a
card game
an mtgo is their their clunky old
online version there's now mtg mtga
which is mtg arena
which is kind of a more modern version
but mtgo
is uh let's look at some images it's
kind of a yeah this clunky looking
interface but it works pretty well
they'd run tournaments on it drafts and
all kinds of stuff so
the software works there's no
particular reason um why the software is
bad
other than maybe you don't like the look
of it or something anyways
it was revealed that they kind of wanted
to
update some old code modernize things i
think they were just looking for another
developer to join the team
they were a little vague about it but
they did start asking some questions
about code to
to kind of gather my understanding of
code and of course i told them that i
was a c
plus developer and so they asked mostly
c
and c plus plus questions and that
interview seemed to go okay
and then i got to the third phase and
the third phase
was where it all kind of went awry for
me and this was
really totally my fault i should have
done something different that there i
had there's a lot of
hindsight 2020 moments here
but also i was sort of getting the
you know i'm trying to think how to say
this i was
i guess i was starting to see that by
this point that
maybe i don't want this job after all
after all it was
sounded like it was going to be pretty
far away i would have had to fly out
there
there probably would have been a final
interview out there wherever it would
have been
this would have taken me away from my
family for
potentially weeks which i wasn't super
thrilled about as i was also i was
currently
working somewhere else full time and had
a hard time spending time
to begin with and so i was in a bit of
this personal situation where
my family was like actually needing me
they were going
through some things some of their own
things and
i needed to be there so i was i was
starting to get this
i don't know like the thing or thought
in the back of my head like hey maybe
this isn't such a great idea
any after all so
the third part was a test they sent this
little code test over email
and i actually still have in my email
but i don't want to show it because i
don't think it's uh
i just don't want to show their stuff
but basically what it was
was in c sharp
it was a bunch of classes and interface
classes
about power toughness loyalty and
basically the effects of magic the
gathering
and it was all mostly empty and the
instructions were to
basically fill out the classes and the
interfaces and and try to make it
efficient and talk about the methods you
use
it was pretty involved
now if you've ever played manchester
gathering you will certainly know
that the rules of this game are actually
quite complicated
sure there's the basics of you go
through your turn phases
but also there's like a lot of little
niche things like the stack rules
uh how bass the base power and toughness
of creatures applies
and how some affects um the order of the
effects on them
based on uh the game state
and things like that and to be perfectly
fair
i was not playing magic gathering at the
time
i well i had taken a long long break
from magic the gathering i played a lot
as a kid i even played in tournaments as
a kid
so i was familiar with what the game was
and the basics of it
but i hadn't played in about 10 years so
i was not familiar with the latest rule
changes with some of the new cards with
some of the
just the new features of the game and
all the little things that came with the
new sets that
came out when i wasn't playing so i was
pretty rusty on this whole
um how everything applies and what some
of these new things were that they were
that was in the code that i was supposed
to logic and reason about like
planeswalker loyalty i had never seen
planeswalkers before
they apparently they came out during my
break so i had to catch up on that and
try to understand it
and i talked to some friends about it
and um
you know some friends that had been
playing magic
and hadn't really taken a break and they
explained the rules and there was also
vehicles and a whole bunch of other
things so
there was a big quite a big knowledge
gap in my understanding of the rules
just because i hadn't played
so long and i will say that i was really
hoping for a d
and d position i didn't expect to get
interviewed for magic but
hey i took what came to me at this point
because it didn't sound like
uh all the people i was talking to had
anything to do with the whole d and d
side of hasbro or wizards of the coast
so
yeah it was what it was and i tried to
do my best on this code test however
i was working 40 hours i was commuting i
was under a lot of stress with
with my family and things
i was trying to resolve there which was
all personal
stuff and basically i just
i totally biffed this this code test
because i didn't spend enough time on it
and there were a lot of factors into
that uh the the not no not understanding
the rules was really big
also um i had barely used c sharp i use
c
plus plus all the time if i have the
option to use
a language of my choice i choose c or c
plus plus
i don't choose c sharp because
i don't have to basically and i don't
want to learn too many languages or at
least i didn't at that time
now i will say that i've used c-sharp
more since then and do have a better
understanding of it
but at the time i was not too thrilled
about having
to learn c-sharp just to do one code
test
i was just already i had enough going on
and i was just like uh
and i and based on the the kind of the
feeling i had that i
wasn't even sure i wanted this job
anymore i kind of just like
went through that code super quick and
won it i
i actually looked at it a couple days
ago because i was curious
i remember after turning it in and a few
days later i got an email back that said
hey we've decided to go different
direction
and i basically said okay thanks for
letting me know and for the opportunity
and we
all went on our way so yeah i got
declined and
when i look back at that code i totally
understand
why they went with someone else
the code was really bad man even looking
at it today
it was really bad you could tell that i
just like
zipped through it and didn't give it a
second thought i had typos
all the comments i left were some of
them didn't even make any sense
one of them was like this broken
sentence that apparently i missed
because i didn't mean to leave that in
there
i just didn't overlook it very much i
didn't spend enough time on it
i actually spent quite a bit of the time
before even doing it just
researching how the all this stuff
should work and
what the proper logic should be so i try
to program it in there and once i
thought i had the gist of it
i ran through all these interfaces and
stuff and did a bunch of stuff
but honestly when i was done the thought
in my head was
there is absolutely no way this is going
to work correctly
i don't think i'm going to get the job
but hey i'm just going to turn it in
anyway because
i'm not going to ghost them i'm at least
going to turn it in but they probably
got the impression
that i had no idea what i was doing and
yeah based on that code i can definitely
see why
i don't really have any regrets about
that though because
yeah i i just i wasn't real sure i
wanted the job which was
weird to me because it wasn't
that long ago that this that working for
this company
wasn't a dream of mine but
once i found out it wasn't for d and d
and
basically getting this code test in c
sharp
when i was totally interviewing for a c
or c plus plus position as far as i knew
kind of annoyed me and
yeah just the other the family stuff was
on me too
so i was really you know in retrospect
i'm really glad i got the opportunity
and i did learn a lot from it
and if i were to do it again i don't
know what i would do different
i guess i would spend more time on that
code thing but
also i might have told i probably what i
probably should have done is i probably
should have declined
i probably should have said hey look i
know we've gotten this far but
uh my gut instinct is telling me that
this isn't this
the position for me although it seems to
line up and everything i have a lot of
external
you know i probably should have just
been open and honest about that but
it's very possible that my tone changed
and i didn't even realize it
and that might have given them a bit of
a red flag too definitely in my
in the code i submitted my tone had
changed because
the comments were not very good like
i think one of the the comments near the
top was something along the lines of
hey this appears to be for magic the
gathering although it doesn't explicitly
say i'm going to assume all that or
something like that because
it literally didn't it was just like
chunks of code
there was no mention of what game it was
for or anything it was just it was
assumed it was for magic because it was
clearly the magic rules i had like you
know a lot of magic keywords but
it was pretty vague so
another thing about this i kind of had
the thought in my head that like if i do
really well on this code
and i don't get accepted they're
basically just going to use this code
and not hire me
which it sounds you know
sounds pretty iffy like why would they
give me this specific of a thing and
want me to implement all the stack rules
if they already have it working you know
stack rules are pretty simple
first and first out system if you know
the order of things it's not that hard
to reason about and code
so i was kind of thinking okay they were
talking about wanting to rewrite and
update things now they're
they're basically having me rewrite the
whole buff system and interaction system
if i do this if i spend a ton of time on
this and do this perfectly
what's gonna happen like there's there's
no way i would ever know if they used my
code and didn't hire me you know so i
kind of had that in the back of my head
when i was doing this code too
and that kind of made me want to not do
it very well because i was thinking okay
i and maybe this is wrong maybe i'm
completely wrong about this i don't
think a comp
that kind of company would do it i've
never known them to be a shady company
your opinion may vary some people really
don't like the company but
yeah i didn't think anything like that
but it i just couldn't help but that
thought was in the back of my head
that if i do really well this don't get
hired they might just use my code anyway
and that felt really dirty
so as as a company i think if you're
going to give a code
test it should not be very robust robust
it should just be like some little
things to make sure you understand
core concepts you should not be
rewriting you should not be asked to
rewrite
the main internal structure
and flow system of their main product
because it takes a lot of time
and to the person on the other end the
person doing the test
they're always going to have that
thought in their head that like
are they just like trying to get free
work
a lot of people like how many other
people have they interviewed and given
the same test
and are they just looking for the the
best one or the most reasonable one but
they're not actually going to hire
anybody
they just want some ideas for where to
go with the code i don't know
so that was in the back of my head and i
i couldn't like help it i don't
think that was actually the case though
i don't think they did that
or were doing that they definitely
couldn't use my code
and you know part of me not reviewing it
very much was
i i didn't want to be able to use my
code i thought that was just such a
dirty tactic that i wanted to make sure
it or i didn't want to make sure i just
i didn't want to be so meticulous and
spend so much time on it for nothing
basically so i was like
look if i'm going to do this i'm just
going to give a quick
you know once over and turn it in and if
it's good enough fine if not then
fine i guess i'm pretty neutral at this
point i already have a great job
everything's fine
so yeah i guess that's it that's pretty
much the story of me applying to
wizards of the coast and and how the
interview went i was really happy to
just to get the interview
as there's the bottom line and in
retrospect i
feel pretty glad that i didn't get the
job oddly enough
and that feels really weird to say
because i still like the company i still
play the game
all right well i want to thank you for
watching and maybe that will give you
some ideas about what to expect if you
apply for other companies and and what
how it may go a little bit
you're welcome to ask questions down
below and i can do a follow-up if
there's a lot of them
but i feel like that pretty much covers
the the gist of everything
all right well thanks for watching guys
i will see you in the next video
and uh if you want to support further
you can do so on patreon they really do
make these videos possible these days
so big shout out to you guys i got a few
special videos come up
coming up at the beginning of every
month i'm going to be of course thanking
you guys and i'm also going to be
asking the patrons for their ideas like
what kind of videos they want to see
this week and i'm going to try to make
as many of those happen as i can so
another perk to joining
is you get to directly influence some of
the new videos that come
out every month and you get to get your
name on screen and all that stuff
and it basically keeps me motivated
because
well the truth is and i'll go over this
at some point i guess but
most new videos i make barely make more
than
a one dollar and that's just the reality
of it so
it's actually come to the point where
i've sort of
realized that it's not really worth my
time to make youtube videos anymore
but the patrons make a huge difference
there
because you know the reason you guys
sign up is because i keep making new
videos
but me making new videos doesn't
actually do a whole lot for my channel
anymore
so that might be partially my fault
maybe i'm making terrible videos
i'm not really sure uh the whole reason
my channel is growing
live is basically my cmake tutorials and
my
blender tutorials so those seem to
actually make my channel grow
every other video i do doesn't really do
anything other than make me like 50
cents to a dollar
and then it's over so yeah this video
here
was totally brought to you by the
patrons i wouldn't have done it if i had
no patron thing i don't think anyway
all right well look forward to more i'll
see you guys in the next one
and thanks for supporting me peace out
cheers to good copy